relationship advice guys relationship
advice we always help them
all right we always help them bro we're
both
ruining our lives
yeah you're right this is mad i'm gonna
keep trying though you know yeah you're
right though man that's true my attitude
needs to change i'm gonna keep trying as
well let's see if we can help this guy
matt farrell asking for help remember
the one guy that had his wife trapped in
the back of the car
and then asked us to delete the video
hey man
dude you submitted it i think you guys
gonna blast me out like that
now my wife's family knows like you
submitted the video
we didn't ask for it yeah his wife
sitting in a child seat in the back dude
and she was like this yeah she was like
i'm 26.
[Laughter]
shout out to that guy hopefully she's
still alive
gang gang buzz buzz fellas my name's
matt i'm from
waterford michigan so me and my
girlfriend been together
for two years uh first you know it was
great my girlfriend man she is just
she's just so rude and mean sometimes
yeah and uh
you know love her to death yeah uh is me
she's a lot of sex it's good she's latin
uh but
man just that attitude yeah sometimes
man it's too much to handle
yup i'm not type of guy man to degrade
women or talk
back to women sometimes you have shaken
them right like that
uh so you know i try not to engage back
there man but you know she's just rude
really rude and mean you know just and
so
what ethnicity bro and i want to be with
her
but it just doesn't seem like anything's
going to change
the way that she she reacts to me and
treats me you know so
nilo vice gang gang buzz buzz brothers
appreciate it man i need more details if
i'm gonna solve this case brother this
first 48
me and detective theo are on it is this
an episode of uh
hawaii five-o this it might be but i
don't know what an
ethnicity [ __ ] bruh you know what i'm
saying this is the easiest thing to
solve
he needs to stop being a [ __ ]
that was aggressive i'm sorry what's his
name brad you need to go back though i
know i knew we're back
that's what they told me anger
management stop being a [ __ ] and look
at me
that's true yeah yeah well was that what
it
was
do they say you get angry because you're
what is that one of the reasons why i
grew up very violent
but so but when they say though in anger
management they say stop being
is that one of the things they tell you
no they don't say it directly right
but it's one of the reasons you were
angry maybe because you were smaller and
like bigger kids were picking on you so
like yesterday
the bigger kid that was picking on me
was my stepfather yeah yeah
okay that's the big kid though
you're right i could handle the kids at
school yeah this is when i got home i
was like damn this is a hard fight
your dad could fight huh bruh yeah
an eight-year-old yeah he could find an
eight-year-old
that's all he got hey but he
he taught me a lot yeah yeah i love him
good got that head work
he's a horrible dude but uh i love him i
feel you man yeah
that guy i mean yeah he just needs some
confidence in himself yeah there's
confidence but also
dude i'll put up with some [ __ ] if she's
fine enough
i'll put him with some [ __ ] bad movies
she might throw a little racist term
hair in there i'm like yeah i guess but
i put up with it dude if she's that fine
man
if that happens i'll leave the room man
but you come back
huh yeah come back with snacks dude yeah
hell yeah
come back with them flaming hot cheetos
i gotta find out this girl's latin
because my girl me sometimes like damn
let's go to a young lady that we have
here we have a young lady on premises
and let's chat with her
because we need some help because i
don't know well i
my girl's not the friendliest yeah
they're latin dude
yeah but do i feel like cats mean to her
man i feel like you put hands on them
look everybody likes to date a girl with
an attitude problem until they have to
date a girl with an attitude problem
people always think it's so fun to date
a passion like you're on a pitbull
speaker might exactly
and you don't want a pitbull when it
comes to dealing with the people
supporting hillary kind of
yes you're wearing the shirt you're
wearing the shirt until it's time to
vote
and y'all put that [ __ ] sticker on
like an [ __ ]
exactly you want that pimple to it's
time to do some pit bull [ __ ]
[Applause]
so you throw that frisbee and he attacks
a family
pills are crazy dude peoples are crazy
they're like felons they're like felons
dude
they kill a family of four it's like
they come back wagon tails
come back with a mouthful of barrettes
you're like damn this [ __ ] got violent
um i'm sorry cat and i think i stepped
over when you were when you're talking
too
we what suggestion would you give us
because yeah if if maybe the man feels
emasculated it sounds like a little bit
but i feel like a lot of girls do that
over time
because they don't respect them no i
think over time
over time it's easy not to respect your
significant other no you're that dick
game right yeah
yeah it is isn't it yeah i don't know
what it is just over time slowly
well you take people you take people for
granted
and then you get really mean to him
big dude you get really mean to him he
take him for granted you know what i'm
saying
you do take him for granted you do you
do man
you're gonna yeah
you forget why you were with them or
what's going on but what did he say he
said that the girls mean and then
first he said she's rude then he said
she's mean i'd have to know attitude
well if she's ethnic though if they
listen
listen bro when they're ethnic and they
got that attitude but they got them
curved what about i gotta put on paper
without eileen warnos dawg she was curvy
dude
yeah you're right yeah
can't handle the curves well if you
can't handle the [ __ ] lizards you get
out the lot you feel me though
eileen warner is the number one live
legend of all time wasn't she
remember her the movie monster yes she
was the number one lot lizard and she
took
she took charge of her life yeah yeah
she was a the only female serial killer
son wait y'all never seen uh
the tina turner movie with ice and tina
bro
no she beat him the [ __ ] up oh well
whitney houston bobby brown
i heard it was good fights i did too
tommy davison told me of a good fight i
heard that
rihanna chris brown i'll buy that [ __ ]
again i'll watch it
she got that reach with the legs yeah
she did i heard she bit him yeah
i heard that too yeah she bit him that's
why he freaked out
dude i'll tell you this i'm friends with
shamwow guy vince right
with who vince from shamwow remember him
god keeps throwing that in my face
yeah all right well
he got accused he got accused of hitting
a woman one time in miami that makes
sense
but the woman had bit on to him like one
of those fish on the side of the
suckerfish yeah and he had no way to get
her off so what did he do
he tried to get him to order food and
stuff he tried to shamwow her off
[Laughter]
and uh and then eventually yeah he used
aggressive force hitting and then so
what happened though she'd take a chance
he called the police yeah out of his
face though yeah
said there was a bite that happened to
that uh soap opera dude who was a dime
piece
he had a wife had a side piece on the
side something happened with the side
piece she bit his lip off yup
that's what you get somebody said that's
a lester holt bit his [ __ ] lip off
dude really look at lester holt dude
here's the number one dateline episode
where's your top lip at
les all right let's get a picture of
lester hold up here dude
really yeah this dude's looking for all
these mysteries and somebody
right his lip right underneath his like
nose right underneath his nose
hey type of lester holds lip yeah yeah
oh
derek definitely uh one of the worst
between derek and chin as far as the
googling skills
it ain't good oh wow
yeah no lips black man got smaller i
don't know
dude bro he can't even hold a mustache
hold on a second bro i don't [ __ ]
know if leicester old is black dude look
at [ __ ] lester holt
you telling me that's not a white dude
in blackface look at him
look at the [ __ ] picture i think he
goes i think he goes chocolate body
24 7. that ain't a [ __ ] black dude
look at him
that's black he black no he's not no we
ain't look at that picture with the
[ __ ]
suit on hey go to his wikipedia it says
it'll see if it says his parents bro
that ain't a that's not a black dude
he's not black look how long his hair is
on the side
uh he's mixed mixed with a lot of white
yes oh god bro oh bro okay all right
you're right about that one that one
look at this
that's a bit much that's a little
aggressive i thought i was aggressive
but that's the best
hold up hold up is that him on the
bottom left there
the same uh this will redeem him is that
lester
that's a black man there on his rise at
the time he might be like a michael
jackson i don't know if that i mean
really maybe sammy sosa did damn yeah he
just
how are you going sammy so what no sammy
schultz gets the lotion so he's white
yeah that's the real thing the whitening
lotion yeah you've seen sammy sosa
lately it's fantastic
he might be a white man i never thought
of my life i've seen over probably 600
episodes of dateline
and you know i've never thought that
until just now it's like it just doesn't
look like a black man to me
yeah well what's sammy that's the
whitest [ __ ] you can damn that is that's
pretty white
that's awesome so
i'm with theo on this case bro damn
lester hold his
white damn case saul yeah i was rooting
for you lester i was
man
[Laughter]
oh no no lester way too white for the
cold maybe the crayola corner bro he got
some paint on wait what's up with sammy
sosa
bro you haven't seen him lately sam and
so so they calling him
sandwiches right his [ __ ]
his ethnicity swam upstream bro
as far away from the black river as he
could get bro he is
but he ain't black he was saying he says
well he was puerto rican black yeah
dominican blacktino yeah i get mistaken
for dominican all the time do you really
i could see that no darker dominican no
yeah probably like if you had a baseball
hat on
no kind of like four times like the
batman of the dominican republic kind of
a little bit
i can see that a little bit he has the
best
dark joke he's just like
yeah brenda's just racist dude i'm the
racist one yeah he was making fun of my
gap and [ __ ] i'm like oh
no i made a reference how cool your gap
is all of a sudden i'm the bad guy
meanwhile he's friends with shamu beats
women
and the head of the kkk duke used to
spot him on the squat rack
but i'm the racist okay okay on bench
press you [ __ ] okay and he's a nice
guy bro he's different swap [ __ ]
supplements duke and i'm racist
because my dad got a little flavor in
the green room and my mom
twerks all right i see how it is what
else we got d
get us up